hey youtubers is charlie this week on
orphan black it is all about blowing
[ __ ] up mrs. s and Sarah divide and
conquer Vic the dick gets molested by
elves nope not really but seriously we
do get to see some awesome Sarah acting
as other clones and we get to meet
michelle forbes character she's playing
Mary and Rachel's boss at the dyad but
real quick if you're finding me for the
first time I try to do orphan black
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything I missed a couple of
episodes but I will have a link to my
master playlist down in the description
so let's talk about how crazy things are
getting careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but I'm
gonna do my top 5 moments and then my
review so number five victa dick gets
molested by elves we need a book of
felix quotes i think of him as like the
punch up guy like when Alison and Sarah
just get way too heavy he just pokes his
head into frame it says something crazy
Vic was totally addictive he deserved
everything that happened to him the
whole Vic Sarah [ __ ] storm wasn't quite
as funny as I expected it to be mostly
painfully awkward I was surprised to
find out though that the police officer
he was talking to was the same one that
tried to get info out of Alison in the
parking lot a couple of episodes ago it
is so funny just watching Alison try to
deal with dumping bodies like Vicks
number for Sarah pretends to be Alison i
always love watching Tatiana maslany do
clones acting as other clones I don't
know why she hasn't won an Emmy for it
yet it is criminal the minute she
started dropping monitor bombs during
their role playing session I kind of
knew Donnie was gonna figure things out
to be fair Alison had to spell it out
for him but we finally get a peek inside
on his head ended his glorious before
that scene I actually kind of expected
him to turn out to be just a regular
monitor just kind of in with the diet
but turns out he was co-opted in college
to just be part of a social experiment
that kind of explains why he's so
terrible to spy stuff all it really
means is is that there's a good chance
he could wind up switching sides so to
speak and helping clone Club before the
end of the season he's like the loveable
goofball of the show which is why that
final scene was so shocking number three
Rachel confronts dr. leekie Mrs S and
Sarah blow [ __ ] up as expected it
totally works there was the added twist
of Rachel's boss michelle forbes siding
with her over a leaky or just asking her
to get rid of leaky they're going to be
a lot of repercussions
from this that we did not see in this
episode I think about the side projects
that leaky was working on like that
artificial womb I think that that was
just the tip of the iceberg I'm hoping
they uncover more of his secret research
later this season there is so much going
on inside the diet right now it's like
kings landing in Game of Thrones
everyone is a liar I think it was really
interesting that Rachel defied Marian's
wishes and let leaky go it kind of
suggests that she might do something to
help the clones against Marion's wishes
before the finale michelle forbes did a
recent interview about her new character
this Marian character and she said that
she's in the last two episodes of the
season and she just gets progressively
weirder Forbes went on to say that she's
the kind of person who's so powerful it
doesn't even occur to her that
subordinates like Rachel would defy her
I'm actually expecting Marian to kind of
rise to the top as the ultimate
antagonist from within the diet this
season so don't be surprised if Rachel
kind of becomes a stealth clone Club
member number two Delphine uses Kira's
stem cells to heal Cosima this is one of
the few major violations in the episode
in case you're confused leaky and
Delphine harvested Kira's stem cells
from a tooth she lost a long time ago
it's really small so there's not a lot
of genetic material they went on to
start using those stem cells to treat
Cosima without her knowledge so they
totally worked so Kira's stem cells are
the answer to this problem but it raises
a whole lot of moral red flags Cosima is
totally right to flip out Delphine
actually seemed like a bit of a mad
scientist during their shouting match
like she couldn't understand what she
was doing was wrong but in the end they
still need more stem cells if they're
gonna help Cosima we even saw in the
teaser for the next episode she's
spitting up blood so it's getting really
really bad it kind of seems like as we
get closer to the finale events are
conspiring to bring everyone back
together in the same location Sarah's
coming back with Kira and Donnie and
Allison are starting to discuss the dyad
experiments so obviously they're being
pulled back to I just can't wait to see
michelle forbes character just sitting
over all of them just working the
strings just to see what her ultimate
plan is and my number 1 WTF moment
Donnie kills dr. leekie I just love how
casually the scene started out leaky
does not even care to give Donnie the
time of day he's like a speck of dust in
the grand design but all it takes is one
random
counter to blow everything up obviously
in this case literally blow up Leakey's
head it is totally confirmed unless
there's a leaky clone floating around
somewhere he's gone for good but his
influence will still inform some of the
really important plot points the
artificial womb he was talking about
that's probably gonna have something to
do with Cosima getting better remember
that camera footage from earlier in the
episode whenever they were operating on
Cosima that was from inside her womb
she's obviously full of cancer and
that's what the stem cells are treating
but I'm really interested to see if
Cosima Delphine hijacked Leakey's secret
projects to help solve the problem or at
least speed things along but now it's
your turn let me know in the comments
below what was your favorite moment was
it Donnie killing leaky was it michelle
forbes characters seeing her for the
first time or was it Vic the dick
getting molested by elves overall I gave
the episode of E Plus as complexes the
show already is I feel like they're
doing a great job of escalating
everything I was kind of bummed we
didn't get to see hellena this week but
I don't expect them to be able to fit
everyone into every episode there's a
ton of characters leaky as a character
is irreplaceable but I think they're
replacing him with the smoking man so to
speak just to explain right now I think
of michelle forbes character as being
like the smoking man from x-files
controlling everything from a distance
and ruthlessly dedicated to this really
ominous plan michelle forbes is pretty
clearly a neolutionists Oh her plan is
to patent humans at some point as
opposed to the proletheans they just
want to homogenize the entire world one
of my favorite things about the show and
something that this episode does really
well is send characters off in a really
epic way like the producers say we're
gonna kill you off but it's gonna be
amazing dr. leekie please rest in peace
you will be missed by no one Donny
sounds like he's gonna be in the run in
the next episode but I think he's gonna
end up turning to clone Club for help
I'm very hopeful for his character the
only alternative is for the dyad or
hellena to hunt him down the things that
I'm really interested in learning more
about right now though are michelle
forbes character she's still very
smoking ban very mysterious learning
what happens whenever Sarah surrenders
herself and cure to the dyad and
learning what rachel is gonna do with
Duncan he's like her father and she just
found out that he's still alive so my
next orphan black video will post next
week after episode
eight years be sure to subscribe to get
it if you have any other questions about
the episode that i missed last week
episode 6 just write them down in the
comments below right now click here for
all my orphan black videos and click
here for my Maleficent review thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow for fire and blood high fives
you